good morning this is a morning mini vlog
mix room and tired 8:38 a.m. I have to
go to work today at Michels work I
freelance there a little bit from being
the entire and you're really tired
you're almost froze so much
Derek knew what's going on do you like
know why I've done doing mini vlog I
thought it may be interesting to do
something quick but now I really didn't
talk about if you don't have anything
good to say
don't say anything you know
good - so - looking back on that block I
realized that that was um so boring
unrealistic dude I had something to talk
about in the restaurant then where you
know I had this table of four British
folks they were all fairly intoxicated
there was something inside me that
wanted so badly to impress them because
they're from a different country
specifically from Britain and means that
they're hilarious anytime that I meet a
British person my brain just
automatically associate Benny Hill it's
a fact I wanted to impress them because
I was trying really hard to impress them
I was the most awkward I've ever been to
any of my tables one of them was getting
crab cakes the other one was getting
ribs and they were gonna share it so
immediately in my head I thought up some
joke about like the UN hesitated and
saying it and stumbled on the actual
words and it's like the you UN I'll be
right back with your drinks
Oh awkward I left me a fairly kind of
bad tip I just assumed that it was
because they were British enough because
I was awkward